hey guys how's it going I am so excited
right now because in front of me is the
new iPhone 10 and I'm shaking I am
shaking with excitement and I would say
that this is an official official
unboxing but I actually could not even
wait until I got home so I kind of
already pre opened this at my friend's
house so here is my initial reaction of
my first moment with the iPhone 10
beautiful
[Music]
oops oh no I made a mistake
until I got home and I put it back in
the boxes but it's clearly already
turned on and already set up but this is
a reembarked a reveal so let's go
through some of this I was already
digging through here because I had to
get the SIM card ejector so that I could
immediately as fast as I could get my
sim card on my iPhone 8 and into the 10
immediately and I just looked down in
this box and it already recognized my
face so what do you know face ID is
fantastic but more on that more on that
let's get into what else is inside of
the iPhone 10 box we've got our little
pamphlet here and there is the SIM card
ejector which I actually put right back
in IV box this thing for this unboxing I
mean could you take a look at this this
is something that I'm sure many of you
have seen before and maybe Jenny Zarek
tweeted ok we need to turn off my watch
notification the SIM card ejector you
get the point we've got our fantastic
wonderful beautiful stickers look at
this next up we've got another piece of
paper with a lot of text on it I don't
want to be bothered with that but what
is this welcome to iPhone it's kind of
crazy when I unbox to the forget what it
was it was the iPod shuffle it was
brand-new and it was so crazy just sort
of see all the old documentation and the
things that they thought were important
to include so now here we are
iPhone 10 here's what it looks like
we've got our face ID set up what is
this oh wow I thought that was a little
piece of some sort of tape but it is a
little arrow that is showing you how to
use your home button which is no longer
there
swipe up what else do we have in here
nothing and here it is beautiful iPhone
10 it's shining it's shimmering it's
splendid it's beautiful it's perfect and
it is
thing and more that I'd hoped that this
phone would be I just hold everything
else it's already on it's already set up
so I can spare you guys that whole setup
process and I just unlocked it face ID
Wow
it's incredible we'll take a look at the
back and it really is much more amazing
in person I mean the glass shines right
through into the silverback it has the
stainless steel bands all the way around
the edge and it really does remind me oh
yes actually of the 3GS this was not
what I was grabbing for but this reminds
me a lot of the 3GS there it is
the stainless steel all the way around
it but really you guys have seen that
before let's take a look at the 10 I'm
try not to shake but I'm shaking with
excitement this is a perfect time for a
slow-mo iPhone 10 montage
[Music]
[Applause]
so you first turn it on it's kind of
crazy because it does take some getting
used to you now swipe off to open swipe
down on the right for your control
center and they swipe down at the top or
on this left hand side that'll take you
to your Notification Center a lot of
people like to close apps so to do that
you just swipe up and you hold so you
just pause here for a little bit you can
switch to the apps that you want to get
to or you can close them press and hold
and that will give you the option to
delete and you swipe up or you can hit
right here up at the top and that will
delete all of your open apps that you'd
no longer want to use one of the things
that I really liked it's on the home
screen is they have access to the
flashlight and a camera right there I
feel like those are the two things that
I'm always struggling to find especially
when I'm walking my dog or if something
really cool is happening and I'm like I
gotta get to my camera I got to get to
it it's right there so you can just
click on the camera or you can swipe
over to give you quick access to your
camera so you got two options click here
or swipe over let's see what else is in
this box so we've got the regular power
brick of course this is something that
I'm sure many of you have seen before
and inside here we've got our ear pods
right here hair pods in the front and
your dongle in the back at this point
I've lost so many dongles that I
probably could have bought an entire new
phone with how much I've spent on
dongles but now that I have the air pods
they don't actually ever need the
dongles anymore so it's quite the iPhone
dilemma we've also gotten here one of
the Lightning cables but you can never
have too many lightning cables one of
the things that people made fun of the
most about the iPhone 10 is the notch at
the top and for whatever reason it
really has not bothered me at all I was
one of those that made fun of it and to
be completely honest with you I didn't
even notice that he was a thing it just
sort of seamlessly integrates into the
phone and another thing that I like is
what I was going to do the apps there's
a little notification up here that says
done whereas before most people would
normally hit the home button but now
there's not a home button so you can
just hit right up there click done and
you're ready to go I was also very
surprised how quickly I adapted to not
having a home button at this point it's
like I didn't even ever have one to
begin with one thing that I was worried
about when I would
my car because I always use my phone for
directions I thought since it's kind of
far away because it's sitting on my
dashboard that it wouldn't be able to
read my face and unlock if I reached my
hand over and guess what it did and it
was dark and everything just worked
perfectly it was quite surprising
because it was one of the things that I
was most worried about so I want to show
you guys how easy it is to set up face
ID I'm gonna go through here and I'm
gonna delete my previous face and I'm
gonna add my new face which is
ironically the same face but whatever so
right in here you have the face ID and
passcode and it asks you to enter your
passcode so I'll enter that here's the
option to reset face ID so we will do
that right here
so I'm gonna do a screen capture so I
can show you guys the setup process for
face IDs so look at the new screen
capture is right up here on the top to
let me know that it's recording so you
guys can see that's usually where this
entire screen would be taken up but
right here it's just this little small
corner so let's go into face ID and
we're gonna add my new face which is the
same face that I had it before so we're
gonna click get started and oh wow
that's a look so let me position my face
and the frame I'm gonna phone a little
lower lower okay there it is so move
your head slowly to complete the circle
continue
move your head slowly to complete the
circle that's what I'm doing this idea
is set up so that's it says you swipe up
you will see that it's looking for my
face looking for my face can't find it
but now we're gonna just go like this
look at my face and it's unlocked
it is absolutely magic now I know you
guys have seen this before on Android
phones I've used it in my note 8 I used
it in my samsung s8 but it's so
different when it's in the palm of your
hand and you're using it on an iPhone
and one of the things that I love about
Apple is they're not usually first to do
things but when they do finally
implement it they are the ones that make
whatever it is that they are doing
mainstream so now I think face ID is
going to be the new mainstream one of
the things that I thought was very
shocking is the an emojis and I've seen
demos of it I tried it at the Apple
event and when they first announced it
but actually trying it and seeing it in
person is kind of amazing
seeing the expressions of a poop emoji
mimic my expressions is kind of
something that you really do need to
experience in real life I'm gonna try to
do a quick little demo for you so you
can see exactly what I'm talking about
I'm going to go into my sister hasn't
message here so hopefully I can kind of
show you guys this at the same time
let's go to the poop emoji and it sees
me and as you can see I'm raising my
eyebrows right here do you see it on
this camera the poop is also raising its
eyebrows so let's do this hey Jenna I'm
just doing another test here on the new
iPhone 10 and for some reason I feel
like every time I started doing a demo
of this my face starts getting weird I
start talking weird and just making
ridiculous facial expression and
watching somebody else demo the N emojis
I think is even more enjoyable than
actually demoing it yourself so let me
know when you guys first see somebody
actually doing this in real life another
thing that I thought was pretty cool is
not only can you send the an emoji z' as
a movie file you can save it but you can
also send them as stickers so if you
want to just send a still sticker just
like you would send any normal iMessage
stickers all you have to do is make that
facial expression tap and hold on the an
emoji with that expression and drag and
drop it into iMessage just like that and
Jenna is just loving this just as much
as I am so I want to show you guys the
size comparison between the ten and the
iPhone eight and it's crazy to me
because this screen is beautiful it is
technically edge to edge just not from
the small notch that's cut out but
what's insane is how small this phone is
in my hand to go from using this for the
past several years to a phone that is
significantly smaller but yet the screen
is actually larger then on the 8th it's
kind of messing with my mind because
it's very hard to comprehend and because
the phone is actually smaller it makes
me feel like the screen is smaller but
it's actually not when you hold it up
next to this so it's basically taking
this 10 and putting it on top of the
Apes and essentially it's just a screen
it is just a screen but it is a very
significant size difference so if you
see these guys and next to each other
this one is almost
the size of the iPhone 8 not plus which
I have here this is actually shocking
this is the iPhone 8 and this is the
iPhone 10 they are almost the same size
I'm kind of freaking out right now
looking at this in comparison to each
other because I had no idea that the
eight would almost be the same size as
the 10 very similar in size the 8 is
slightly smaller we put them up side by
side just like this here's the 8 and
this is the 10 obviously you can tell by
the vertical cameras I'll be doing a
camera test and later so you guys can
check that out but in the meantime can
we just stop and stare
cue the OneRepublic song iPhone 10 in
comparison to the original iPhone right
here got it from the bottom now we're
here I phone 10 verse 3GS Kenya take a
look
iPhone 10 verse iPhone 7 plus at the
time of making this video I've only had
it for about half of a day and in that
half of a day it has far exceeded my
expectations and that's something that I
didn't actually think was possible like
I was excited for this phone and now I'm
really really excited for it and it's in
the palm of my hands guys I just wanted
to give you a quick little look of the
new iPhone 10 I have so many more fun
videos for you guys coming out so if
you're not already subscribed to my
channel make sure you guys click
Subscribe and let me know in the
comments below if there's anything that
you'd like me to test out here on the
iPhone 10 also I would love to hear from
you guys
did you preorder one if you did preorder
one when is your ship date but I'm gonna
tell you what this phone is fantastic
and I am so excited for you guys to see
the videos that I have coming up I'm
freaking out okay I will see you guys
later I'm gonna go at this video now so
see you later
[Music]